[Music]
the ballistic knife
you're probably not used to seeing one
in this configuration but um
this is what they look like when they're
not loaded so in uh in black ops
obviously we see
typically an overhand grip which is fine
for fighting with a knife
and then of course the blade is shot out
of the
body and you can see how that actually
works in real life
so ballistic knife might imply some sort
of kind of
gunpowder or propellant it's not that at
all it's just spring power and then that
locks into the grip with a little spring
catch and that is your trigger
i was chuckling to myself watching the
clips because the idea of
reloading this or loading this quickly
is pretty hilarious if you actually look
at one so
let's say that i've just uh shot shot
the blade i reach for a reload from
somewhere stuff that in there and then
while the enemy are shooting at me i
desperately try to compress but i'm not
gonna be able to do that
um the only way you can load this is by
pressing it
into a wall or the ground or i don't
know the corpses of your enemies or
something
really really hard until that shelf
locks into that trigger so you are not
reloading this
it's a one-shot deal much like a
throwing knife and of course
throwing knife is really far superior to
this thing
um we've not shot our knife but the
range on it is going to be extremely
short
further than you can stab obviously
but uh nowhere near the 100 200 meters
that
we seem to get out of it in the game but
um yeah not so practical
definitely doesn't work how it does in
the game and just carry another magazine
for your pistol
the uh famas an iconic weapon in popular
culture
standard french service rifle currently
being replaced by the heckler and [ __ ]
um
hk416 it's just a really cool looking
gun uh we have to admit that
and of course bullpup configuration so
the
uh essentially the uh grip
sits in front of the bridge face that's
that's how i define a ballpark
magazine reloads um pretty uh
pretty faithful just [ __ ] slightly
with my gloves here but um
catch on the front pull down and pull
the magazine out in the same
motion and insert fresh magazines clicks
in place so
pretty well depicted um and it
crops up in all sorts of things
the heckler [ __ ] g11 um known in
uh firearms study circles as a unicorn
gun because of its rarity and
uh so much so that we don't have one
which is pretty depressing
what we do have is a very historic piece
of wood
um well wooden plastic this is from the
g11 program
you would actually have someone carve
mock-ups out of wood
and really all it does is give you the
the basic ergonomics
of the gun so a really cool artifact but
not a real g11
i have visited the uh our counterpart
collection in
koblenz in germany and i have seen a
room
full of these things and i was able to
disassemble one and have a look at how
unbelievably complicated it is it's just
uh a cuckoo clock now why is it so
complicated
it's all to do with getting three
bullets
out of the barrel at the fastest rate
possible to increase your chance of
hitting the target
and if you do hit the target of
incapacitating them
the g11 has this rotary chamber
that has to convey around um or
to a line around with the uh barrel very
unique system and the magazine that sits
on the top in the real gun
actually reciprocates um it moves back
and forth you can see this if you find
another video of it in being fired the
magazine moves back and forth because
the mechanism inside is moving as well
hugely complicated very very very clever
and yeah there's this unbelievable three
round hyper burst which um i think i
think black ops does a reasonable job of
replicating
that mag dump on the um spinning targets
or
moving targets really brings home the
sort of the amount of firepower you
could bring to bear with a 50 round
magazine and three round hyper burst so
that i think that represents what they
were going for
quite well and then we see in the reload
animation um that the the character is
sort of ripping the magazine out of the
front of the gun getting another one
aligning it
um with the barrel and slotting it back
into place and that's that's how the gun
is
reloaded and a nice touch which we don't
see on our mock-up
instead of a cocking handle or charging
handle you pull back and let go
we see the clockwork winding which is
how
um how a fresh round round is being fed
into the rotating chamber
and how the chamber is aligning with the
barrel so the the
almost alarm clock wind-up reload is
quite fun
and realistic
the an-94 automat
nikon nova shocking russian but um there
you go
uh we are fortunate to have in the royal
armory's
collection an example uh full disclosure
this is what's called
an mmg which is a factory produced
dummy essentially the whole
gum is essentially a gun within a gun
appropriately enough to be like a
russian doll there's
there's a complete firing gun mounted
inside this
um and it's incredibly clever you can
see that the magazine is offset
it's hardest to see in the game but it
is faithfully depicted
and that's to do with having to queue up
two cartridges
for the hyper burst feature i'm sure
that the hyper burst feature of this
weapon is 1 800 rounds per minute which
is extremely fast for an assault rifle
and the way the game depicts the sights
is interesting so the front there's
nothing normal about this gun
at all the front sight is that
distinctive shape which is that shape
so that you can have a night sight in
the top
so you can put that out this doesn't
have it but a glow-in-the-dark element
in the top so if you aim through the
middle it's a normal front sight if you
aim through the top
it's a glowing front sight for nighttime
use and then this bizarre rear sight
which isn't depicted in black ops 2 at
least not in the configuration that we
have in the clip
which is a wheel that you turn with
different
numbered ranges so the sights are weird
the mechanism is insane the only normal
things about it are the pistol grip
which is
derived basically a copy of the ak74
magazine is the ak-74 magazine the butt
stock is
uh similar to the ak-74 again
everything else is nuts including this
muzzle device which recirculates gases
to produce
just the right amount of pressure to
make sure that the gun works reliably
yeah a bit of a bit of a unicorn gun
that wouldn't really give you much of an
edge
the the so-called b-23r
pistol from black ops 2 this is where
black ops starts to diverge from reality
so i don't have an example to show you
because it doesn't exist
but what it's clearly inspired by is the
beretta
93 r r standing for rafika
which is italian for rapid the folding
foregrip
is pretty essential um for any kind i'll
say accurate not an accurate fire but um
getting bullets to go away vaguely where
you need them rather than in the ceiling
uh so you fold that down and you put
your thumb through the trigger guard
which would normally be a bad idea but
that's how this works
in the game it's space equivalent of a
future equivalent
has its folding foregrip permanently
folded up
we have the selector on the side here so
single shot just like a normal pistol
to the three dots and you get three
rounds just like the
futuristic version three very rapid
shots
the three-round burst makes much more
sense than fully automatic you have to
be
very skilled very strong or both to keep
the gun on target with an automatic
self-loading pistol like this
three round bursts you've got a chance
of holding it on for long enough of
course in the game
it's not really a problem and it allows
you to hit with pretty much three shots
every time
mostly fictional weapon doesn't really
offer any capability
over and above the real thing
thanks guys for watching this breakdown
of some of the more iconic weapons from
the black ops series
and we hope you join us next time
[Music]
you